what good morning Millennials and
welcome back to the toast happy Tuesday
I am honored and humbled to be joined in
Studio by a major celebrity also happens
to be my husband hey Ben Soffer how you
doing I'm Dern wonderful darling how are
you wonderful wonderful yeah because
we're together and we just celebrated
six years of marital bliss it is but
it's also because any day that God
allows me to wake up in the morning is a
good day wow he's feeling spiritual
after Rosh Hashanah any day that I wake
up it's a good day also any day when I
eat good sleep good
hydrate well you're with family like how
can you wake up bad I can't I can't I
can't wake up bad I'm loving this
positive energy and Outlook you're
bringing to the show today Ben it's
because I went into Jackie's fridge and
I found uh an almond cookie butter
creamer wow that just really made my
coffee just zip it rocked your world it
was really really tasty like think of
like that Biscoff cookie I'm assuming
that that's exactly what it was where
you find on a Delta flight yeah yeah
yeah crumbled up
use a bunch of artificial sweeteners put
it into some cancers concoction and use
some almond paste and then put into my
paste I think so right it was a paste it
was pasty no it wasn't paste it was it
was Liquid yeah okay but you mix it with
almonds you're misrepresenting the
Almond creamer no I'm not yeah I think I
described it perfectly you said it was a
paste I said that when you mix it you're
using almond paste I don't think that
how do you how do you think that they
get the almonds into the Almond creamer
I think they use almond milk got it how
do you think they make almond milk you
soak almonds in water yes and then what
does it turn into
almond milk
a base no it's not a paste I think it is
no I see people making almond milk on
Tick Tock all the time yeah you see
people making one little bottle of
almond milk these people are making
trillions of gallons they're big
corporate I don't know how we got to
this part of the conversation but I'd
like to leave immediately thank you so
much for joining us here today yes how
are you feeling in terms of you know
your a few upcoming appearance on the
toast you were on last week I don't
think it was our best work really yeah
that Friday episode I thought it was
great I mean it's always nicer to be in
studio but yeah but I thought it was
great okay yeah like you're saying how
am I feeling like on this episode I'm
feeling fantastic I just told you I'm
feeling fantastic I feel like you're
being very defensive like I'm I'm
I was just asking a question got it yeah
no I'm feeling great very excited for a
great episode where we go through some
wonderful news stories before we do that
we have to update everyone I told
everyone on the podcast yesterday about
the gift that I got you for our six year
anniversary oh yes it was a wonderful
wonderful gift I got a cameo from Sir
Lewis lit uh and he was just as Charming
as ever did you experience Jackie talks
to me a lot and she spoke on the podcast
yesterday about kind of like an
uncomfortableness of receiving a cameo
like it just feels like you're seeing a
celebrity like a little too up close did
you feel any of that no I love it okay I
loved it okay I didn't think that it was
weird I do I do think again as a
celebrity myself right it is a little
strange that we needed to pay for it and
we couldn't just I'm 100 sure that we
know somebody who knows somebody who
knows something he's Jewish Mr Lewis lit
yeah I just I wanted to pay him what he
was due like he's a working actor
they're on strike absolutely no he he
deserves the coin I'm just saying that I
do feel that there were ways to get to
him without Cameo there's some something
about Cameo that feels a little bit like
prostitution I think it's like a great
business and I kind of wish I thought of
it myself do you think it feels like
prostitution though
um you're being paid for your work
that's called capitalism like you work
and you get paid yes one life isn't
prostitution would you say that you're a
prostitute of my podcast yeah you come
on here and you [__] it yeah I do I use
money and run I use it yeah I'm still
waiting on that money from day one from
day one you talk about bad royalties I
have the worst royalty deal in the game
Ben is an unpaid guest and he does it
out of the kindness of a heart of his
heart because he loves you guys so much
and he loves showing his feet on the
podcast that's really what he by the way
while you may not get paid directly by
me for coming on the show you do get
paid because you further your career as
a foot model and then you get all these
people reaching out sending foot pics
yeah a thousand percent and also you can
still go to sports society.com pink
lemonade and buy the flavor that rocked
the freaking world you can also use code
toast you should use 10 off
um and you can also listen to Good Guys
the number two greatest podcast in the
whole world of course I'm on number one
it's not a legitimate statistic let's
just keep that in mind why not like
you're not actually number two yeah
you're probably like number two in our
hearts what the hell number two you know
okay son are you really number one yes I
don't know if you saw the charts over
the weekend we were number one yeah we
charted one set number two
I don't think that you did you didn't
see number two number two in all
categories
oh wow yeah we're very scary so we're
lying today never really give it a
listen
um whether it's number two or number 69
or number 100 whatever it is
good guys
the more people that listen the more
episodes we can record it doesn't have
to be one day a week guys it could be
five I like that little face you made
after 69. yeah it was nice right did it
remind you no shut your mouth
um we don't do that okay stop why did
you bring that up
um moving on let's talk about the Roman
Empire
okay
and I have nothing to say I don't want
this dumb trend is where guys want to
talk about the Roman Empire no that's
not that they want to talk about it it's
that women discovered that men are
constantly thinking about the concept of
the Roman Empire just like in general
and they've been asking their husbands
and partners Brothers we're not we're
well you're not no because you don't
know what it is no we are not I know
what it is it was the empire built by
the Romans when in
phew
of course it was before Christ
was it no it wasn't of course it was uh
A.D actually no it was definitely it was
not before Christ
I was thinking the BC's the aeds the D's
we researched it yesterday because we
were me and Charlie were both like
what's so special about it and it really
was like one of the greatest
like times in history the Romans like
that part of History they created so
many things that we use today amazing
like what roads love a road sanitation
like literally taking sewage and putting
it like outside of the city love it you
know kind of basic cert like so many
tools that we use for surgery so we've
made no advancements in like a trillion
years no we have but I think what the
what was so great about the Roman Empire
if I'm recalling correctly is that like
there was I don't know if there's been a
time where so many significant medical
civil like all these different types of
advancements have been made in one era
amazing yeah so I guess that's why
people are thinking about it because
it's quite amazing so it seems like
you're thinking about the Roman Empire
and you are pretending that it's
Millennial men no I'm trying to Gaslight
into thinking that I'm the one thinking
about the Roman Empire when really it's
you I only learned what the Roman Empire
was yesterday so check yourself before
you get the [__] kicked off the show
[__] interesting first of all second of
all what do you think the female
equivalent of the Roman Empire is what
are like historical events that women
are always thinking about Jack and I
were saying yesterday some options could
be the Titanic
they could be the Holocaust
what do you think
I don't think that the Holocaust is
gendered I think oh wow I think uh both
men and women think about the Holocaust
that's actually a very good point I also
don't think that the Titanic is gendered
no sorry you're wrong on that the
Titanic is gendered I mean literally
with this submarine it became
non-gendered everybody's thinking about
the Titanic let me just say it's a
submersible and no sorry Titanic is for
the girls no just the Titanic is for the
girls you're wrong move on just the
movie you're wrong
what time what time period is there
supposed to be a time period it could be
like a historical event a tragedy
I don't know okay
I don't know okay I'm not a historian
well that's the day the music died the
day
the Music Died they were singing
bye bye miss American Pie shave it to
the leather but the letter was right
this should be the day that I die it's
not my clean dead I was gonna say like
you are Don McLean is he dead I don't
know and to be honest he could come up
with me on the street and slap me in the
face and I wouldn't have no idea who he
is same I'm just saying but I know that
I am married to Don McLean I'm Don
McLean you literally are why like how do
I explain that to people like you're you
are Todd McLean I love that song I Love
American Pie you do love that song
and The Day the Music Died is a day that
women
think about often
oh you think well do you know what that
song's about yeah The Day the Music Died
do you know why the Music Died no like a
private plane I forget who was on the
plane like some famous musicians like it
went down really and that was The Day
the Music Died see I'm gonna see you
didn't even know that let me just make
sure I'm not making that up because it
does sound like like kind of fake but
what is the day the music died about I'm
like fairly certain it's not what the
song's called so I don't know if you oh
it's not no
yeah American Pie American rock and roll
buddies oh musicians Buddy Holly Richie
Valens the big booper JP Richardson were
all killed in a plane crash near Clear
Lake Iowa together with pilot Roger
Peterson so he was singing about his
friends wow who is Buddy Holly because
this man is very famous there's also a a
wonderful song Yes Buddy Holly is
extremely famous uh is is Buddy Holly
Weezer
is that different oh my God is Buddy
Holly no no the song the song Oh I think
he meant is he like in the bandwiz or
Mike Benny's he's very dead in the 50s
no what do you mean you look just like
Buddy Holly Oh yeah yeah Mary by the way
you literally like made a face like out
of some [__] there's a full song in
that moment where you thought Buddy
Holly was a part of the band Weezer I
definitely reevaluated all my life
choices like that was borderline
embarrassing for me and for you
[Music]
well now that we cleared that lunacy up
should we dive into the stories which I
can't lie
they're not what
what it's just funny whenever it's me
and Jackie's not here you're always not
gonna lie guys the stories they stink
okay I honestly let's talk about that
let's talk about that I hate picking the
stories I do it yesterday they stunk it
up too I don't know if it's just me or
like whenever I have to pick the stories
nothing's going on in the world but it's
annoying it's annoying and so I just
wanted to let people know like the
stories are not storying today now we'll
make them a story of course and Ben gets
it we'll make him sing Ben gets into bed
last night and he's like oh my God
should we talk about Shannon I'm like
what happened to Shannon Ford he goes
DUI the door I was like
first of all you're on a first name
basis with Shannon midor I'm just saying
everybody knows who Shannon is in the
current news if you literally get into
bed and bring up the name Shannon which
by the way that sounded wrong but in the
current news the current news cycle
literally Shannon bedore I mean Shannon
Ford is one of my best friends yeah she
works with us love her like why would I
not assume you were talking about
Shannon Ford because Shannon bedore is
in the news
struck a building
she killed nobody what she killed nobody
are you sure positive really but you
read that she killed migrants
are you just like trying to make a joke
make a joke oh God by the way it wasn't
even a joke you like could have gone
along with it no I was like maybe I
missed something she didn't kill anyone
and that's like why people are like
gonna you know let this cycle out of the
news like she's not yeah I get it cool
moment ruins okay sorry continue what
did I do no nothing like it could have
just been like a you know like people
talk rumors spread no but the thing big
thing happens no the thing is is that
like you sometimes believe like things
and you like will misread something and
so you could have gone on the rest of
your life thinking China midor killed
some migrants I didn't and I just wanted
you to know that actually that was in
fact not true I didn't okay well you
know you thought Buddy Holly was in
Weezer I didn't you did I did let's talk
about that now like you did I didn't it
seems though is it seems as though you
do spend your life though thinking what
am I
what are my potentially misconstruing
yes and not just assuming that I know
the facts oh yes I do did you feel like
you just uncovered some big secret about
me no like for sure I'm just saying I
know the facts okay well let's see if
you know the facts in today's story
right I did try to pick them a little
tailored towards you very good so are
you ready Ben yeah
is that a big problem no I don't think
you'll be able to hear the baby's crying
but like we're in a house with babies
it's okay okay and I don't think the
microphones
are you ready Ben I'm ready for it oh
wait are you ready kids
aye aye Captain I can't hear you I I
captain Oh
oh here are the fast Side Story is that
you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by Loft not enough people
talk about how Loft has actually really
cute and trendy pieces they touch on All
Seasons with the most trendiest Trends
and they're always offered at a great
price so with October being around the
corner their new arrivals in October uh
Sweater Weather officially begins you
can settle into the Colder Weather with
cuddly sweaters easy to wear Blazers
super soft cords unexpected third pieces
and so much more chili season is upon us
if you want to make a fire cultivate A
vibe get a chili on make sure you got
like a stunning cardigan some really
cute loungewear from Loft it's really
cute also if you're a working woman I've
heard like most of my friends who work
in the office are always at Loft they're
always talking about the Blazers the
pants it's really like kind of a go-to
destination for actually cute work
clothes they are back and better than
ever with a fall collection a fun
feminine fashion loft is orchestrated a
modern mix of all day any day pieces
that offer endless versatility we're
talking plays on proportion soft
touchable texture as exciting new ways
to layer with ideas on how to
effortlessly put together and pull off
our latest have to have styles so this
fall collection is definitely one to
celebrate and includes everything you
need to build a stylish feel good outfit
top tip to toe let's
um keep showing up for ourselves and
each other by wearing what we love as a
thank you for listening today from today
through January 1st 2024 so you have a
good amount of time to get your wardrobe
together use code toast loft.com and
you'll get 25 off your full price
purchase exclusions buy see podcast
description for terms again that's
through January 1st 2024 use code toast
loft.com for 25 off your full price
purchase today's episode is also brought
to you by
Poland Branch Bolin branch is a fabulous
brand it is a brand it's holistic here
at the toast I'm at my you know New York
Studio I got my bowling Branch at home
I'm in my Florida Studio I got my
bowling Branch at home they have the
best sheets the best bedding accessories
the best bedding all around your bed
should be a place of Higher Learning a
place of Solace of Peace of restoration
so start investing in your best sleep
with the softest most luxurious sheets
from Bowling Branch bowling Branch
sheets feel incredible because they
don't cut any corners and they know that
quality takes time each sheet set is
slow made for an unmatched softness with
100 traceable organic cotton that feels
unbelievably soft for years to come
the signature hem sheets which is what I
have at home I also have it at here in
my Florida room from Bowling Branch our
best seller for a reason they use the
highest quality a hundred percent
organic cotton threads on Earth each
sheet set is slow made for a superior
softness and a better night's sleep they
feel buttery to the touch and are super
breathable so they're perfect for both
cooler and warmer weather they're loved
by millions of sleepers including a
major celebrity in Benson for celebrity
head to sleep last night in your bowler
Branch wonderful cool
calm collected love that for you they
come in 10 versatile colors and in all
sizes from Twin up to California King
they're designed to feel incredible for
all sleepers they're made without toxins
free from synthetic pesticides
formaldehyde and other harsh chemicals
so sleep better at night with bowling
Branch sheets get 15 off your first
order when you use promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com that's bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast exclusions apply Seaside for
details all right Ben you ready to dive
in before we dive into the first story I
did just get a text from Joey camasta
what do you say uh saying that a suit
star died
what yeah but I don't know who this is
hold on it can't be a suit star oh I
literally have no idea who this man is
do you think Joey is pranking you and
you think and she's from Daily Mail but
I don't know who that is
who is that person first of all very sad
very sad oh he plays Harvey's brother
ah yes oh that's so sad it is after
Valiant battle with bipolar depression
he was only 43 oh my God that's thank
you for thank you Joey master so you
enjoy your capacity text like that he
dmmed me yeah just like you know he was
thinking of me he was thinking of you
that's really sweet well that's a
terrible story it is a terrible story
it's also like a very clickbaity
headline like yeah because he was
probably in a lot of things he's not
most prob known for suits but no no not
a star a great person sure but no star
of Suits I'm saying no I'm saying I'm
sure he's starting a lot of things oh
yes yes okay so our first story I picked
uh for you today because I know you jerk
off to Olivia Rodrigo okay that was
disgusting sorry she's like a it's like
also not even true I know you just love
her like I can't you guys win by the way
I can't just enjoy women's music no
without jerking off to it yeah thank you
now you understand that's what explain
what now I understand I'm your wife I
make music now I understand what
I'm your wife yeah I listen to your
songs too you should be obsessed with me
I am obsessed with you no I don't think
you spend enough time thinking about me
got it and obsessing over me got it I'm
sure that's true yeah
um
I just wanted to tell everyone a story
that Ben gets in bed last night I was
reading and listening to the new Olivia
Rodrigo album and he
gets in bed and he says like oh I think
I told the story yesterday on the toast
ignore me okay ready what about how she
plagiarized Miley Cyrus yeah like you
thought that was Hannah Montana that you
thought that was like your original I
mean I don't know if you guys know this
but it's not about China it's Miley
Cyrus start all over it was after the
Hannah Montana years but a really great
song that also could have been sung by
Hannah I love that song um I have like a
skill where if I hear a song I can pick
up the notes
from other songs I don't know if
everybody has this skill but I'm really
good I will say like I clown on you all
the time you do have that scale I'm
really good at it yeah he'll be like
this actually sounds and it'll pull up
like the most obscure song and you know
what they do kind of sound alike so
really I can match chord progression so
Charlie puth if this comes across your
desk
I can work with you so you're coming for
a Charlie puth's snack no I'm coming to
work with Charlie why would you want to
work with Charlie puth because he makes
like cool music like that but he does it
yeah he does what oh we hate Charlie
puth yeah oh you don't know that I
literally hate Charlie puth you're not
allowed to even remotely respect him I
don't I like him get out I like him get
out I like him no Ben we hate Charlie
puth in this house all right Give Me One
Reason
his social media his personality his
face I like it Ben I'm in take it back
no
I'll cancel Good Guys no you can't have
that power no you don't I do you don't I
do no you don't I do you don't I'll
cancel Good Guys no you can't I can you
can't I can you can't I can we'll switch
uh people yeah you know good luck I will
cancel good guys say that you don't
respect Charlie puth nope Ben we're not
going on with the podcast until you say
you don't respect Charlie good I respect
him so I can't I can't do that I can't
slander another man that has a great ear
for music
a fellow celebrity I can't
can't do it so stalemate here yeah
we're at an impasse it is what it is
gorgeous pillow of Theo
I can't believe you're disrespecting me
on my own show this one is fine you know
who I love oh
Hitler
no
why would you say that oh
that was incredibly out of pocket like
it's a good transition who do you like
hate no one I'm a lover no you're not
you hate everyone who knows you're
always talking about people oh I know
him but I can't say it on the podcast oh
who
oh yeah I love him how does that make
you feel it just makes me think that you
have bad taste that's what I think about
you and Charlie puth okay sorry even
okay
our first story Zach Bia reveals whether
he inspired Olivia Rodrigo's Breakup
Song vampire so Zac Bia is insisting
that the song The scathing Breakup Song
is not about their short-lived romance
he did an interview with GQ and he was
obviously asked I think a lot of people
just like they guessed and then now
everyone just assumes like they just
believe that it's about zakbia
um he said I don't really think it's
about me I think the internet just ran
with it we hung out we're both busy and
we ended up not furthering our
relationship there was never any drama
you know look I'm in the industry so I
know how a song gets made he explained
before giving props to her songwriting
chops the song's so big and so awesome
look a heartbreak song for the
summertime it's an undefeated formula
anytime I've spent
speculatively the subject of a song or
the focus of a tick tock Trend whether
grounded in reality or not it's like
I've never it's never been up to me to
address it because the scale of it is so
widespread 100 million people have heard
this song the only thing I can address
is my own life I can control what my
friends think and the creative output
that I have and things like that
okay Zach bsn's pretty smart I I want to
say that was like a good quote I also
think his explanation of the song map
like I believe it he was like we I
remember when they were like spotted out
it wasn't
for a long period of time it wasn't a
million things like I actually believe
like they dated fizzled like not
everything has to be like big
catastrophic drama like I believe his
explanation that the song isn't about
him yeah and the song could easily be
about no one
right like the thing that we like to do
and by we I mean girls uh is is
listening to musical women coming from
musical women no no coming coming from
musical women
coming from musical women
coming for musical women coming for the
women
music not the musical women is that it
always needs to be oh who's she singing
about who is this with when in reality
these songs are typically not even
written by these people I'm sure Olivia
writes her own music I'm not saying that
but like songs are just the way that
Zach Bia said you know a heartbreak
summer a heartbreak song It's a formula
it's a formula you know easy it is to
write a heartbreak song I went to the
park looked at her she looked at me and
said I'm not talking to you anymore and
I went home and I screamed and shouted
and I cried in my room until it went
dark and then I came out in the morning
expecting to see the sun I see the Sun
but without her it was a cloudy day and
I cried until the next one
see or break
there's there's no there's no sun
without her okay just backtrack a little
bit to what you said like I think you
were trying to insult women being like
women do no I wasn't and you know what I
I think in what you didn't realize
because you're a man and you're stupid
is that you really were just
complimenting us yeah like women We're
not gonna like lay down and just let
people tell us things like we're gonna
ask questions we're gonna inquire we're
gonna investigate like never stop asking
questions never take no for an answer
you're gonna go deep yeah like we could
sometimes it's just on the surface we're
intellects sometimes a song belongs on
the surface I will say like I think a
lot of times when people like try to you
know decode what a certain song is about
by a singer who clearly doesn't write
their own music like that's a big waste
of your time I don't want to call people
up like we know who doesn't write their
own music and we know who does so people
being like who do you think the new
blanket song is about it's like nobody
they didn't [__] write it they just
like rolled in and sang it but like
Taylor Swift
Olivia Rodrigo these are people we can
definitely assume that they're writing
about someone right from their own
personalities understood understood so
what's your favorite song on the Olivia
Rodrigo album and when are you guys
gonna go on a date
I have to look at the song list I
thought you're gonna take a look at my
calendar I have a look at the song list
I wanna key his car I wanna break his
heart sit you right back up I wanna kiss
his face with an uppercut I wanna meet
his mom and tell her son sucks yeah I
won't
okay what's your favorite oh I like that
one what's that song get him back yeah
that one's pretty solid which is
All-American [__] All-American [__] is
solid that's the one that sounds like
start all over and the truth is
vampire was a single for a reason that's
good you love it it's good you want to
marry it no do you want to watch down
the aisle at your second wedding to
vampire by Olivia Rodrigo wow all right
good to know blood sucker good to know
give me your hand [__]
Fame [__]
that's you bleeding I am a Fame [__]
because I'm married to a celebrity it's
true you're gonna have my limp hand this
whole time stop give me your hand hold
my hand
second wedding you're being defiant
second wedding oh my God you're supposed
to be a celebrity like take it back
no
take a joke
take a joke no
well I guess today's the day the music
died wow okay all right I take it I take
it back I take a joke I take a joke
um excuse me
I'm joking for literally every single
time that you've uh yelled at me on this
show which I'm sure somebody could put
together a long clip please be clearing
my throat
that throat clear tops them all wow if
anybody should be understanding it's you
I don't understand I literally just
choked on my own show and you don't even
ask me if I'm okay you just come and
accuse I knew you're okay well we're
really on edge today okay let's let's go
back to like how we were on our
anniversary like we were so loving yeah
let's go let's do that all right are you
ready for our next story it's an update
I'm so sorry I feel like I don't know if
people keep caring about the Saga but
honestly I do who
so yesterday we were praising Bill Maher
for continuing to bring his show back
and give you know the people who work on
his show paychecks again and not not so
much praising him for bringing his show
back for praising him for making a
decision and sticking with it unlike
Drew Barrymore who posted and deleted
five apology videos and then decided not
to come back well now
we spoke too soon because Bill Maher has
delayed the start of his show citing
strike negotiations so the comedian who
last week vowed to put his topical HBO
program back into production now says he
will delay it for a little while longer
here's what he said
my decision to return to work was made
when it seemed that nothing was
happening and there was no end in sight
for this strike now that both sides have
agreed to go back to the negotiating
table I'm going to delay the return of
real time for now and hope that they can
finally get all this done all of TV's
late night series have gone dark in
recent months due to the strike but Mars
said he would no longer stand by as so
many of his below the Line crew were
going without pay
so I will say I appreciate his uh
explanation
like what we were saying yesterday is
like Drew Barrymore kept releasing these
statements being like we are a global
show that launched during difficult
times like just say why you're bringing
it back like just say and Bill Maher
when he was bringing it back was very
clear he's like there's so many people
who work on the show who are not a part
of the strike they can't feed their
families and you know what like we're
gonna bring the show back and it's gonna
stink because we're not gonna have
writers but people will get paid and I
appreciated it it's because we were like
why is Drew bringing the show back she
didn't explain
um now Bill Marsh not bringing the show
back but I will say I do once again
appreciate his direct he just posted on
social media and he said exactly why I
guess this whole time they haven't been
negotiating with
the streamers because they never got to
like even a remotely like halfway point
so they've been on strike not
negotiating but I guess now they've
returned Fred Drescher and Bob Iger are
back at I got it
go Fran go go Franco she's the best that
said like
um what was his name again Bill Maher
Bill Maher um
if people are going hungry then why
aren't you paying them now
like why are you waiting no I get it he
doesn't pay them the networks too but
the Network's not wasn't going to in his
fictitious scenario where it was they
never reach oh he was gonna go back to
HBO and continue to produce a show and
get all of his employees paid
from HBO like everybody would go back to
work for HBO so why doesn't he do that
now well he said now that these
streamers and networks are back to
negotiating with sagin wga he's gonna
wait I know but they're hungry no I know
so which one is it it's it's both you
see what I'm saying no but it is both
that's like the whole point of a strike
where it's like tough decisions being
made yeah they are tough they are tough
I don't think this is anything that gets
resolved too quickly no me neither I
feel like it's gonna be a while I didn't
even know that they were back to
negotiating well
inside baseball now we know now we know
now we know variety shows like a really
bad picture of Bill Maher honestly like
knockwell if that was Miami best
um okay are you ready for our next story
I am but are you ready for our next
story that's brought to you by ring
concierge I am are you yes because ring
concierge is the leading luxury Jeweler
committed to designs by women for
everyone ring concierge offers
accessible on-trend and wearable
everyday fine jewelry for how the Modern
Woman stacks and layers her pieces ring
concierge has fine jewelry made to be
worn every day and they create custom
handcrafted engagement rings and
specialize in getting you the biggest
diamond within your budget rincon's here
she makes fine jewelry at every price
point and they are a favorite for a ton
of celebrities I have to say this is one
of my favorite Instagram accounts to
follow ring concierge has the most
beautiful pieces I love watching like
their Bridal engagement rings being made
it's so beautiful and they're um
earrings are some of my favorite too I
actually recently from two separate
people got two different gifts from
Marine concierge and they're such
beautiful earrings they're like Timeless
pieces they wear so well they're really
beautiful
um
and of course we have a discount code
for you guys which is so fabulous you
can shop the fine jewelry at ring
concierge.com that's
r-i-n-g-c-o-n-c-i-e-r-g-e.com use code
toast20 for 20 off your fine jewelry
order
um it's just I can't believe that we
have a promo code for ring concierge I
feel like they're one of the most
fabulous Brands and like we did that so
the code is toast20 t-o-a-s-t-20 at ring
concierge.com get your holiday shopping
started early buy something for yourself
for someone in your life if you're
thinking about getting engaged maybe
like send the website your fiance your
boyfriend's way you know it's a nice
name it is right yeah okay our next
story is a little plastic surgery news
Heidi Montag is revealing that she got
part of her chin sawed off during her
2009 plastic surgery overhaul so she's
reflecting on her November 2009 plastic
surgery overhaul including getting part
of her chin sawed off and how it
impacted her final season of the hills
with her husband Spencer I just I wanted
to talk about this story because if you
were there you remember in 2009 like the
hills was everything it was everywhere
they were Paparazzi pictures of Heidi
and Spencer like every single day and
she had gotten like a bunch of work done
on her face and then they had this like
big reveal Ben it was the biggest deal
in the world at the time like when she
revealed her new phase and like she did
look so different but now in hindsight
like I think we're so used to plastic
surgery like it's really not that crazy
she like just looks like she has like
some filler and
maybe like a chin implant
um but if you were there you guys
remember like the CR it was the craziest
thing that ever happened we're like like
people were crying like it was so
psychotic and also I'm just excited that
she's talking about it so she had said
at the time my surgeon was like oh it'll
be a quick recovery a few months and it
took me over a year to heal I could
barely talk with my jaw I just had part
of my chin sawed off it was really a lot
just dealing with that at the eight when
she was 23. and she was so beautiful
before at the age of 23 she notoriously
underwent a whopping 10 cosmetic
procedures at once shortly before
production picked up for the sixth and
final season of The Hills the surgery is
performed by the late Dr Frank Ryan
included a chin reduction updated breast
augmentation rhinoplasty revision a brow
lift liposuction facial fat injections
and pinning her ears back among others
holy smokes she said I wasn't even in a
place to film and I kept saying I'm not
a person right now I need to heal and
recover and I'm not doing well
physically like I'm not able to
literally show up like I was I thought
I'd bounce back and be able to be on TV
like I was after my first cosmetic
surgery but there was just way too much
done and each thing took too much time
and it hurt so bad I was just in an
immense amount of pain oh my God I like
totally had forgotten about this Saga it
sounds horrible horrible
10 plastic surgeries at once yeah it's
tough it's tough what plastic surgery
would you want to get done to your face
oh you're perfect the way you are but if
you you know had to
my it's funny my uh co-star on good guys
actually recently got the surgery and he
speaks about it under eye bags bags my
bags are getting really bad they're like
literally not they're really bad that's
not a real problem so I'd like to get
this uh this done I think no you don't
need that what else would you want done
oh so what do you think I need done
that's a good question
I think you definitely need an egghead
removal surgery rude
you do yeah I guess it could be I could
shave it no no I'm totally kidding I I
was not saying that question I don't
think you literally need any plastic
surgery are you sure there's nothing on
you I would change sure except your love
of Charlie puth
fine I don't think there's a surgery for
that I do no I don't it's called the
lobotomy I don't think so yeah I don't
think so this is so sad but um so
interesting that she's sharing that time
and I didn't realize I thought she got
that done when the hills was over
but it's a weird choice of timing before
the final season
yeah and just I don't know trying to
squeeze it in you squeeze in like a
teeth cleaning you don't squeeze in a a
chainsaw to the chin right she said she
was obviously it was obviously her
choice but she wasn't aware of the
repercussions including a near-death
experience it wouldn't happen near death
they called Spencer at one point during
the surgery and told him I basically
died and I wasn't doing well she
explains that at one point her heart was
beating only five times per minute after
she was allegedly administered the
incorrect dose of the opioid Demerol for
pain relief so here's the problem I'm
proposed this is like a crazy story wait
we had to have nurses at the house for
months to help me recover so we're
dealing with that and then we have these
producers saying say this and say that
and we're just like we can't do this
wow this I'm Pro they have a new podcast
by the way so this is where they're
talking about I just want to go yeah
sorry you sure yeah
I'm pro-plastic surgery you want to get
something done you get it done yeah that
said unnecessary surgery presents
unnecessary risks so unless it's really
important really important just saying
Joan Rivers
she by the way didn't die getting
plastic surgery what should I getting an
endoscopy a routine endoscopy even worse
see even necessary things have risks so
the unnecessary is really unnecessary
just saying okay pastor also okay Pastor
Ben
also I was going to ask why we're
talking about this like why this came up
and it makes sense if they have a new
they have a new podcast they also
clearly have an unbelievable publicist
no this is actually like such an
interesting story and
like so sad it is sad
what of the work that I have had done do
you like and dislike
I think I think I think that all of the
work that you've had done has been quite
tasteful thank you uh not like God
altering right well the chin was a
little God altering why
you didn't have anything shaved no I
just had like the fat taken out okay
that's not God altering and lip filler
what do you like about that do you I
feel like you don't like that I I don't
but I don't think you do too much of it
if you do I just haven't noticed but I
haven't done it I think your lips look
good I haven't done it in a while yeah
so then when you have done it I haven't
liked it so yeah don't do when I have
done it I feel like you don't like the
texture of my lips it's just
weird there's no such thing no yeah no
it's too much no your lips are they're
good what's wrong with your current lips
nothing which is why I I'm leaving them
I understand all right now we're going
to talk about your girlfriend Shannon oh
yes another girlfriend she's ashamed
she's entering counseling after her DUI
arrest one sorry she should be ashamed
um to counseling like I I hate this
thing where I know that celebrities are
coached to have to say certain things
because they know that's what writers or
the public or the network or somebody
wants them to say like it's I think it
was Kyrie Irving when he made those like
terribly anti-semitic uh comments and
then was like oh but don't worry I'm
going to the uh Holocaust Museum to
learn with Rabbi shmuli yeah and it's
like no like I don't believe you no it's
it's like PR
um strategy at this point and I'm not
going to question the woman's age but an
older woman a younger woman don't drive
drunk no like it's just it's just so
there's literally no excuse when Uber
exists when taxi exists lifts and when
you're like a woman of means like get a
driver oh wait no it's also it's just
terrible like I was reading the comments
under this and it's like like At first I
was thinking like oh people are gonna
like be nice to her like feel bad
forever and it's literally just comments
of like my 14 year old son was struck by
a drunk driver like what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
okay so here are the details her friend
Jeff Lewis was a radio show revealed
that his close friend Shannon Madura is
seeking treatment after she was arrested
for a DUI and a hit and run early Sunday
he said I'm happy to say that she's
gonna be entering counseling this week
so I'm so happy about that
the flipping out star explained that
Fedora called him after the incident and
said that she's quote accepting full
accountability uh who else would
obviously and she's quote ashamed and
embarrassed he said I don't think
Shannon is an alcoholic I think as her
close friend I think she's going through
a lot of personal struggles right now
and I think that she's probably has been
leaning on alcohol but I don't believe
she's an alcoholic he also confirmed
that she was in a car accident that
night and got injured but nobody else
was hurt
like I get it like people get a pass
when they're young right I'm not being
ageist here I'm just saying like when
you're young you think like nothing can
happen to you and you think you're
invincible and you drink and somebody
makes a life-altering mistake and it's
horrendous but when you are older
you have learned and you can't you can't
you can't drive drunk you can't do it no
I agree you can't do it like I'm I I
really am not a judgmental person I
think that
I'm really um like understanding of
people's flaws and I'm sorry there's
like this is the one thing like I'm
gonna judge someone to hell for this
this is actually a huge thing for you
yeah like if you even have like if I
have like half a glass of wine like have
nothing Claudia's like no you can't
drive no I don't believe in like having
one cocktail and getting in the car like
like when we're going somewhere and
someone's gonna drive they'll be like
I'll have a beer I'll be like I will not
drive with you like maybe I'm a little
extreme but first and I don't even know
why I'd rather you be extreme I don't
know why you didn't have a like a yeah
but sure I'm not I don't have like a
trauma connected like I just think it's
so [__] stupid it is I know why I'm a
logical person it is stupid and in this
day and age when literally you could get
someone to pick you up in 10 seconds on
your phone why you would get in a car
drunk is beyond me and I'm sorry like I
am judging I think this is shameful and
I think it's gross yeah agreed and I
don't know what counseling you can
possibly have for drunk driving
especially if he's saying she's not an
alcoholic no but what is what counseling
can you have what I mean well I guess he
was saying she's going through like a
lot of personal issues so maybe she
needs to go to counseling for those
personal issues got it I I just I just
don't know yeah no driving drunk no I
like literally hate this I
love it thank God nobody was hurt thank
God nobody was hurt how fast was she
going she wasn't going particularly fast
but she was going actually fast because
she was going around a bend and when she
I saw the video of it when the car you
know started to turn it came up
unexpectedly and she literally drove
into a building but how fast is she
going
um let me see if it says
and how far is she from her house
like how long was the drive she was
embarking on okay I don't know I don't
have her like her and how drunk was she
do we know that I have no idea where she
was going but right now she's going on
my list of people I'm upset with but so
nobody knows how far she was from her
house nobody knows how fast she was
driving nobody knows how drunk she was
if you want to go read the police report
sure I'm sure you could do it because
now I also would like to know just
saying because I like to play Both Sides
I just want to know was she truly drunk
was she a little bit tipsy was she going
five miles an hour and she was next to
her house there are some things if she's
putting out public statements via her
friend Jeff Lewis saying she's ashamed
I'm entering counseling I take full
accountability that [__] was drunk yeah
that [__] was wasted that [__] was
driving fast yeah
and I'm upset with her I'm upset with
her yeah it's no good it's no way now
it's no good
it's no good and she was like posting is
she filming
I don't think so but I'm sure cameras
are up now
no I asked if she was filming because
then like maybe you could put a little
bit of accountability no I'm sorry she
wasn't filming because when they do film
yeah production they always show up in
in Suburbans like production has cars
for them everywhere smart yeah yeah that
encourages all the women to drink and be
crazy for the show so definitely and
then takes them home right safely safely
yep and if there was like actual
producers around I don't think anybody
would have let Shannon get in a car yeah
understood no she was definitely um
I'm so mad yeah it's not good it's not
good are you ready for our fifth and
final story I am it is our fifth and
final story that's brought to you by
State Farm ooh the State Farm personal
price plan helps you create a plan that
gives you options so you get an
affordable price and it comes with lots
of benefits like the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and an affordable price just for
you because after all life is just
better when you can personalize your
experiences so think about it like this
what are your music playlists podcast
feeds and social media Scrolls all have
in common spoiler alert they're a
reflection of you and we all know that
my social media are full of you know
currently Roman Empire Trend lots of
Olivia Rodrigo I'm sure yours are filled
with Olivia Rodrigo yours are probably
filmed with uh what's on your social
media like
good guys oh God oh my God's Brits and
that's what the State Farm personal
price plan has in common too it gives
you options to help you personalize your
coverage so that you can protect what
you care about most and it's all at an
affordable price just for you so you can
see more of yourself in everything you
love
are you ready you wanna do it with me
like uh
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
would you you went like a little rug
dude I do like a good neighbor State
Farm is there hey is it again ready
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
what tune are you singing call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan prices vary by
state option selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
again call or go to statefarm.com today
to create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary today's episode is
also brought to you by roback I think
it's safe to say that everyone's talking
about roback if they just launched their
brand new jogger and Hoodie sets and we
can't take them off they're so soft so
comfortable and just perfect for the
fall they use their vsoft Fabric and the
name says it all it is the softest
fabric that they own whether you're
lounging around or having a casual day
out and about these jogger sets are for
you like I'm living in the age of jogger
sets and I couldn't be more pleased
about it I think like in order to look
cute and comfy it's a very unique
scientific formula and robek has
absolutely nailed it they have you
covered in the jogger sets but they also
have you covered for the men in your
life whether it's their performance
hoodies their polos or their joggers
it's all the men we know where if you
want your man looking good then get him
in row back just head to roback and like
take care of all your needs for the
upcoming season for you your man
everyone in your life you'll look cute
you'll look stylish but you'll also be
comfortable which for me is like the
number one priority When shopping for
clothes for me it's like function over
fashion I need to look good I need to
feel good and roback is the perfect
place for that their hoodies are
fabulous I keep a lot of them down here
in Florida because Jackie's house is
always cold because it's so hot outside
and so like jogger sets are perfect for
podcasting I look really cute
and with fall right around the corner
make sure to check out rowback use code
toast on roback.com for a generous 20
off your first order of any fall
essential that's spelled r h o b a c
k.com and you'll get 20 off with code
toast on everything for yourself and the
men in your life check them out now okay
our fifth and final story is some I just
have to say very quickly you have some
wonderful sponsors I know and you do the
ad reads so eloquently oh my God they
are just like so lucky to be advertising
on this show
thank you
just sometimes you listen to ads like on
other shows you're not calling anybody
out and they really phone it in yeah
yeah and you don't and I too don't when
uh I do an Android on good guys we're
just kind of two really authentic
podcasters you would say yeah and you
know we appreciate our sponsors we do
thank you for the sponsors you know
keeping the lights on here today and
make sure to support our sponsors
whether that be roback State Farm
bowling branch ring concierge whatever
it is and use our codes across the toast
and good guys uh you [__] off right now
you've taken it too far
use code good guys okay Starbucks is
facing a lawsuit good [__] them for
their no sorry sorry sorry sorry
Starbucks if you're willing to Pony up
and sponsor any of our shows I will
retract that sorry they sponsor the
toast what the hell yeah they're ready
to drink beverages they're so good we
have them in the studio oh so then we
must be careful with this story well no
like we're just facing we're just
reading the facts they're facing a
lawsuit for a fruitless fruit flavored
refresher drinks so they were ordered by
a federal judge on Monday to face a
lawsuit claiming that several of their
refresher fruit beverages lacked a key
ingredient
fruit
it's not that crazy a judge rejected
their request to dismiss nine of the 11
claims in the proposed class action
saying that a significant portion of
reasonable consumers would expect their
drinks to contain fruit mentioned in the
names so here are the drinks consumers
are complaining that their mango dragon
fruit mango dragon fruit lemonade
pineapple passion fruit pineapple
passion fruit lemonade strawberry acai
and strawberry acai lemonade Refreshers
contained none of the advertised mango
passion fruit or acai the plaintiffs
which are a bunch of different people
said that the Main Ingredients were
water grape juice concentrate and sugar
sorry and that's Starbucks misleading
names cause them to be overcharged they
said that this violates their State's
consumer protection laws the plaintiffs
are [__] this is what happens in
suits no but yeah and they're always
[__] it's like people that are
literally looking for something wrong
with something to get a page yeah no
it's like an ambulance Chaser it's like
people who are the tourists didn't hurt
anyone nobody if you're going to
Starbucks PSA if you're going to
Starbucks for your daily dose of fruit
in your pineapple mango refresher that's
a thousand calories huge problem agreed
huge problem but also anything that has
lemonade at the end you know lemon need
isn't a real fruit right well they're
not complaining that there's no lemons
they're complaining that there's no
mango passion fruit or acai but I'm just
saying lemonade I I wanna I if I were
the judge in this case I would say
you're both wrong plaintiffs you're
[__] annoying go get a job instead of
like you know trying to exploit
major companies like just go do
something else but Starbucks sorry you
can't be out here being like an acai
refresher that has no acai like that's
called false advertising it's misleading
the consumer like sorry you have to do
better or put [__] fruit in your
[__] drinks yeah but can you also
just ask as the consumer what's in this
drink no I'm sorry like we live in that
type of country where like we're all
just lying to each other yes no I don't
think every day no I I I'm with actually
you know what you're right I shouldn't
because if I walked up to Starbucks and
I ordered a cup of coffee I wouldn't ask
is this real coffee was this or is this
you know muddled up poop it could be
right
look we have to have some faith in our
institutions agreed right agreed but we
don't I stand with the pine tips no I
don't
I don't I don't I stand with the
plaintiffs if they came across this in a
way that wasn't looking for a payoff but
unfortunately it was unfortunately by
the way Starbucks was saying what you
said when they wanted to get those cases
dismissed it also said no reasonable
consumers would have been confused and
the Baristas could have sufficiently
dispelled any confusion if consumers had
questions
yeah they said that the product names
describe the drinks flavors as opposed
to their ingredients and the menu boards
accurately advertise those flavors
I
said I don't disagree but the judge this
is literally like an episode of Suits
but the judge said that unlike the term
vanilla the subject of many lawsuits
nothing before the court indicates that
mango passion for an acai are terms that
typically are understood to represent a
flavor not an ingredient I agree with
the judge no no I I stand with Starbucks
on this one when you go let's just bring
some Brands into it right when you go
and you pick up your delicious
diet raspberry Snapple yeah are you
expecting there to be real raspberries
in it
no okay what's the difference that these
refresher drinks have like chunks of
stuff in it
no they don't oh wait no maybe they
don't you're just making that up in your
head okay wait so that's a good weight
or when you get a peach schnapple
there's no Peach I think there is peach
flavors yeah there's also acai flavors
that's the that's what they're saying
there's just no real acai
there's also pineapple flavors there's
just no pineapple drinks typically don't
have real fruit in it they're drinks not
a smoothie is it called a smoothie no
it's called a refresher okay hold on I'm
looking up the peach tea ingredients
it's not going to be anything you want
to see
I believe in snap all of course doesn't
mean it doesn't taste great
zero sugar peach tea this is Diet Peach
Temple where do you find the ingredients
it's gonna be a bunch of stuff natural
flavors or even maybe even artificial
flavors filtered water citric acid tea
aspartame potassium citrate natural
flavors and malic acid yeah look there's
a man because I guess no I guess the
difference is with Snapple they're all
different teas and they come in
different flavors so you know that
there's not
the actual fruit in it because it's just
flavored these drinks are advertised as
it's what are called strawberry
strawberry acai it's called the
strawberry acai refresher and no there's
multiple drinks it's called they're
strawberry mango mango dragon fruit
mango dragon fruit lemonade pineapple
passion fruit pineapple passion fruit
lemonade strawberry acai and strawberry
acai there are two options for all of
these people including you you're a
plaintiff apparently no I'm just saying
they're a stamina yeah no you can't
because there are two options if you
really thought that there was fresh
juice in there either it would be a
smoothie
which is clearly not because it's called
the refresher and they have no blenders
yeah right no they do have blenders two
they don't oh they do have blenders okay
but not for the fruit stuff no no
two it would be a fresh squeezed juice I
don't think that there's fresh squeezed
dragon fruit you can't even squeeze a
dragon fruit how do you get the how do
you get the juice out I think that's
your original claim that like anybody
going to Starbucks for their daily dose
of fruit like is a deeply unwell person
um having said that like I think legally
they've got some some ground to stand on
these plain tips that's what I believe
yeah I believe
oh I believe
agree to disagree have you ever sued
anyone no
and I'm very against the whole thing in
general I I've I've sent a strongly word
letter I absolutely hate I'm sorry I
have many friends that are in this
profession
I just hate lawyers I hate the idea I
hate the idea that we need to have them
I think there are some fantastic lawyers
that are doing the right thing in a very
corrupt Society but the fact that I
can't shake hands with somebody and my
word Works stinks oh you're a big fan of
the verbal agreement I am a huge fan of
the verbal agreement well you're a
sucker see you are a sucker fan of the
contractual agreement let's see you're
the reason and yeah somebody crosses me
I'm going to sue their ass like that
publicist who sold four thousand dollars
for me see because this is the world
that we live in where there are those
publicists and if those publicists
simply didn't exist then we would need
lawyers unfortunately you're living out
of fantasy you're living in a fantasy
true you run a business don't be dumb
get a lawyer we have one they're very
expensive yeah multiple we have multiple
they're very expensive ugh after
watching Suits I should have become a
lawyer like it looks horrible but like
rewarding yeah especially when you work
on the right side of the law right which
not everyone does in suits no and not
everybody is in general so true cool
what kind of lawyer would you be I think
I'd want to be
um oh what a great question
like
the truth is if I'm living in a society
where I could be any type of lawyer like
the suits big corporate lawyer yeah but
like do you want to do mergers and
Acquisitions like Louis Lee does it does
Finance Harvey does definitely not
Finance okay yeah M A sounds nice m a
sounds nice I also just like like
entertainment law like I'd want to be
like a couple really big celebrities
like favorite lawyer yeah that sounds
nice too because they only do like a
couple deals a year like it's not it's
also probably really fun to sue big
companies like the the jobs that these
like plaintiffs like the lawyer that
they have a legitimate claim yeah
exactly because you get a big chunk of
that settlement and then it's fun yeah
like the person that came after Subway
tuna for not having tune in and that's
like probably fun but it's also blasts
for me let me ask you a question Subway
tuna got sued because oh by the way that
[__] up oh so you stand with the
plaintiffs for Subway of course so you
stand with them there's no world in
which tuna shouldn't have tuna in it and
there's no world in which strawberry
acai should not have acai in it no not
sure because it's a flavor tuna is not a
flavor it's a food but Subway could
argue it's a flavor no they can't yes
yes they can the ask you a question so
Subway got sued because it was found
that their tuna salad in their
sandwiches didn't have one did that
actually end up coming out as true yeah
you're positive yeah you're positive
than the end of it Subways tuna doesn't
have tuna okay I don't think that's true
I think that that was a uh baseless
claim that was made but Subway tuna
lawsuit
not tuna
do you speak your nose on my show no I
tried to pop my ear but it wouldn't pop
okay so a woman had filed a lawsuit
against Subway claiming that their tuna
isn't tuna it was dismissed see
wow bastards coming from I tuna Subway
has some really really solid considering
how big they are by the way did you see
how much money Subway just got sold for
two weeks ago Subway sold to Arby's
group wow I'll ask you two questions one
how many stores do you think they have
and two how much do you think they sold
for I think they have 40 000 stores 21
000 stores okay that wasn't a bad guess
no and how much do you think they sold
for
10 billion I was gonna say two billion
10 billion ah how does Arby's have that
much money Arby's stinks and I've never
seen anybody eat there I'm sure that
Arby's is a uh conglomerate that owns a
bunch of these and this is to me this is
the most interesting thing we've talked
about all day but tuna Arby's crib no
like the fast food conglomerates oh I
love qsr Quick Serve restaurants
what a cash cow okay so God I've already
own a bunch of Wendy's Arby's group is
actually called Inspire Brands and they
own Arby's restaurant groups Duncan
Wendy's
see
hold on I think there's more Jimmy
John's see
Buffalo Wild Wings Sonic Drive-In other
way talking about a monopoly
Cece's Pizza I don't know that one Dunn
Brothers Coffee and Mooyah oh Baskin
Robbins too
wow they're killing it and Mr donut
which is an international franchise yeah
and now Subway yeah you're right there
at the bottom of the list
wow like I love I would love to be like
a magnate of like I'd love to own a like
50 fast food chain yeah like I'd love to
be like the largest McDonald's like
franchisee or something yeah it would be
amazing how much would be spicy oh and
everyone I would do meet greets at my
McDonald's I'll get free food how much
does it cost to buy a McDonald's I don't
know does it depend where definitely and
I don't know how much it costs to buy
McDonald's
um I think a Chick-fil-A franchise is
like half a million dollars oh if I
remembered okay how much does a
McDonald's franchise cost most
McDonald's franchise owners and
operators have entered the corporation
by purchasing an existing restaurant oh
to open a new one
requires a total investment of one to
two million dollars oh but if you buy
someone else's yeah for whatever they
whatever they're willing to sell it for
I guess
yeah you know and then you make 150 000
a year so it would take you like 10
years to make your money back
unless you start a fast food chain of
your own
attorneys warm bowls just saying turdies
warm balls
yeah I feel like there would be a class
action suit that would come against you
for having turds in your warm bowls oh
well no someone would like find like a
speck of poop because but then but then
but then they couldn't sue me because
I'd be accurately oh true interesting
interesting you are turdies I'm getting
out ahead of it you're getting out ahead
of it cool right all right yeah we're
gonna start a fast food chain turn these
warm balls maybe we'll work on it no
everybody wants turdies warm balls and
warm bowls are you know the future
interesting thank you for being here Ben
thank you darling I love you very much I
love you too and you know I love you
more oh you better I know you know I
feel like we were kind of at odds this
episode we weren't you just have
something against Charlie puth that I
won't understand
you just have something against women
that I won't understand this is true The
Day the
Music Died cut do I have to do my outro
okay cool thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast the Monday
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday in YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe give this
video thumbs up also available
podcast videos
I did see that clip what the hell is
public radio right yeah
did you hear that yeah the printer has
come alive in Jackie's Studio somebody's
printing something
oh
well some nerve this place is haunted we
gotta go have a great day guys love you
bye